This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在这样一个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是英文单词TWO。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。可在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难学步》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习艰难的方式。
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into today's episode, though, I do want to let you know. that we will be talking about some heavy topics today, including self-harm, suicidal ideation, and grief. So if you are particularly sensitive to these topics, please consider your need
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析我们20多岁时的心理。不过，在进入今天的节目之前，我想让大家知道的是，我们今天要谈论一些沉重的话题，包括自残、自杀意念和悲伤。因此，如果你对这些话题特别敏感，请考虑一下你的需求
to listen to this episode right now. It will still be here tomorrow, in a week, in a few months, or even a year when you feel more mentally prepared to come back to it. So please remember, your mental health is always the top priority. So if you do need to be, you know, any further assistance now or after listening to this episode, there will be links in the description and I'm sending you a lot of love and a lot of healing. Okay, so today I want to take a bit of a vulnerable turn and talk about something quite personal to me that I've existed with for many, many years and that is high functioning depression. Depression that is almost, I would say, invisible from the outside, but deeply taxing on the inside.
是否要收听这一期的节目。它明天、一周后、几个月后甚至一年后当你觉得心理准备更充分时，依然会在这里等你。所以请记住，你的心理健康永远是第一位的。因此，如果你确实需要，你知道的，现在或听完这期节目后获得任何进一步的帮助，简介中会提供相关链接，我向你们发送许多爱和许多治愈。好的，那么今天我想做一个有点脆弱的转变，谈谈一些对我来说相当个人、我已经与之共存了许多许多年的事情，那就是高功能抑郁症。这种抑郁症几乎可以说是，从外表看是隐形的，但从内部看却极其折磨人。
the kind of depression that makes you push and push and push yourself so that it may seem like you're okay and that you're doing well, maybe even accomplished, but everything just takes 1% more and more from you. And inside, you know, you are really struggling despite taking care of everything on your list, despite appearances. This kind of breed of depression, I guess, it's a lot more common than we think. and yet we have no idea of the numbers. We have no idea of how many people are secretly hiding behind a very high functioning
这种抑郁症会让你不断地、不断地、不断地逼迫自己，好让外表看起来你一切都好，你过得很好，甚至可能很有成就，但每一件事都在一点一点地榨干你。而你自己心里知道，尽管你处理了清单上的所有事情，尽管表面光鲜，你其实真的在苦苦挣扎。这种类型的抑郁症，我想，比我们想象的要普遍得多，然而我们对具体数字一无所知。我们根本不知道有多少人正秘密地隐藏在一个非常高功能的
appearance because we don't talk about it and because it's so hard to recognize when it is occurring. People who have high functioning depression don't get help. They don't feel seen in the typical depiction of what depression should look like. For those of us in our 20s as well, I think it's also. so easy at times to conceal this kind of depression. And it's so easy for us to feel like that is the appropriate path, that we should be busy, we should be having fun, we should be pursuing success. You know, these are the best years of our lives. And sometimes we believe, you know, I have no
外表背后，因为我们不谈论它，而且当它发生时很难被识别。患有高功能抑郁症的人不会寻求帮助。在抑郁症应该是什么样子的典型描绘中，他们感觉不到被看见。对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说，我也认为，有时掩饰这种抑郁症是如此容易。而且我们很容易觉得那是正确的途径，我们应该忙碌，我们应该享受乐趣，我们应该追求成功。你知道的，这是我们生命中最美好的岁月。有时我们甚至会相信，你知道的，我没有
reason to be depressed. You know, that that's not, that's not me. I'm in these spectacular, youthful years. I should be happy. I should be happy. And that's where we really need to fix our misconceptions around depression. Not just that it's not a bad word, but also that anyone can experience this, even if your life seems perfect, even if you seemingly have it all together, even if it doesn't look like it from the outside. Even if people would say you're thriving, the private battle could look very, very different. And so today, we're here to talk about it. We're here to talk about what high functioning depression looks like, how. to notice it in yourself but also in others.
理由感到抑郁。你知道的，那不是，那不是我。我正处于这些壮丽、青春的岁月里。我应该快乐。我应该快乐。这就是我们真正需要纠正对抑郁症的误解的地方。不仅它不是一个不好的词，而且任何人都可以经历这一切，即使你的生活看起来很完美，即使你表面上看起来一切都很好，即使从外面看起来并非如此。即使人们会说你在蓬勃发展，但私底下的斗争可能看起来非常非常不同。所以今天，我们在这里讨论它。我们在这里讨论高功能抑郁症是什么样子的，如何
Why it is so invisible, what creates that concealment, what creates this nature or breed of depression, and, you know, the involvement of stigma, of hyper independence, of childhood trauma, of being a high achiever, what all those things have to do with it. But also, how to take care of yourself, even when you don't, quote, look the part, even when you feel the pressure to keep it all together,
在自己身上以及在其他人身上注意到它。为什么它是如此隐形的，是什么造成了这种掩饰，是什么孕育了这种性质或类别的抑郁症，你知道的，耻辱感、过度独立、童年创伤、作为一个高成就者所扮演的角色，所有这些事情与它有什么关系。而且，当你不符合所谓的外在形象时，当你感受到必须维持这一切的压力时，如何照顾好自己，
and additionally what I wish our family, our friends, our partners would know about this experience and how they can help us and so, so much more. So I'm actually pretty excited about this episode. I have wanted to do it for a long time, but, you know, it's quite private. It's quite a personal experience. And, you know, I kind of kept leaning away from it, but it feels like the right time to do it. I hope that it is, if nothing else, informative and makes you feel seen or if you are a friend, of someone experiencing this, a partner, a loved one, helps you understand their lived experience
此外，我也希望我们的家人、朋友、伴侣能够理解这种经历，以及他们如何能够帮助我们，还有更多更多。所以我其实对这一期节目感到相当兴奋。我很早就想做了，但是，你知道的，这相当私密。这是一种相当个人的经历。而且，你知道的，我一直有点避开它，但现在感觉是做这件事的正确时机。我希望，至少它能提供信息，让你觉得被看见，或者如果你是经历这一切的人的朋友、伴侣、挚爱，能帮助你理解他们真实的生活经历
more. So without further ado, my lovely listeners, let's get into it. So I have this theory, and it's a theory that I've had for a long time, and I talk about it with my friends a lot. But my theory is that, at this point in time, society expects any person who is mentally ill to fall into one of two categories. They are either sad or they are bad. And I'm I'm going to explain this a little bit further. But based on media portrayals, stereotypes, news stories, public opinion, people who experience mental ill health are either depicted or seen to be dangerous, harmful, scary, ready to scream at you, hurt you, they're violent, they should be off the streets.
更多。所以，废话不多说，我可爱的听众们，我们开始吧。所以我有一个理论，这是一个我很久以前就有的理论，我经常和朋友们谈论它。但我的理论是，在当今这个时间点，社会期望任何有心理疾病的人都落入以下两种类别之一。要么他们是悲伤的，要么他们是坏的。而我，我将进一步解释这一点。但根据媒体的描绘、刻板印象、新闻报道、公众舆论，经历心理健康问题的人要么被描述或视为危险的、有害的、可怕的、准备对你尖叫、伤害你、他们是暴力的，他们应该被赶出街头。
That's how, you know, we see news articles written about this, that people who have mental illness are dangerous, we see them depicted in a really poor light. or or you are entirely miserable, you are locked in the house, you look forlorn and terrible, you don't shower, you don't get out of bed. It's like that scene in Bridget Jones, like where she's eating ice cream and watching TV, like locked in her apartment for months, but constantly. And there is no in between. There is no room for nuance.
这就是，你知道的，我们看到关于这方面的新闻文章的写法，患有精神疾病的人是危险的，我们看到他们被描绘成非常糟糕的形象，或者你完全痛苦不堪，你把自己锁在家里，你看上去沮丧而糟糕，你不洗澡，你不起床。就像《布奇·琼斯日记》里的那个场景，她吃着冰淇淋看着电视，像这样把自己锁在公寓里好几个月，而且是持续不断的。并且中间没有灰色地带。没有留给细微差别的空间。
Either you are pitied or you are feared. And if you don't look like that, well, you must be fine. must be putting it on. It's this terrible catch-22 whereby if you meet the stereotype, you are treated differently and you are expected to hide away. But if you don't, well, then you must not be unwell enough. You must be lying about what you're experiencing. It also, I think, really lets people continue to believe that, you know, well, poor mental health, it's not that widespread. People are just making a big deal out of it because a lot of the people they do encounter don't match their preconceived notions, you know, their colleagues, their roommates, their family
要么你被同情，要么你被恐惧。如果你看起来不像那样，好吧，那你一定没事。一定是在装病。这是一个可怕的进退维谷的困境，如果你符合刻板印象，你就会被区别对待，并被期望藏起来。但如果你不符合，好吧，那你一定病得不够重。你一定在谎报你的经历。我认为，这也确实让人们继续相信，你知道的，心理健康状况不佳，并没有那么普遍。人们只是在小题大做，因为他们遇到的许多人并不符合他们先入为主的观念，你知道的，他们的同事、他们的室友、他们的家人
friends who they come across every couple of months, they might be suffering with extreme anxiety, depression, bipolar, OCD, any number of mood disorders or personality disorders, but because they don't look like the stereotype, they're easily ignored as being part of that community. So it really does hurt everyone in multiple ways the way that any kind of stereotype will. Like you cannot siphon down and generalize the entire experience of individuals experiencing mental ill health. And you most certainly cannot put them into one of two buckets. Either you are bad or sad, like I said. So this really brings me to how we have been taught to see depression, specific.
每隔几个月就会遇到的朋友，他们可能正经受着极度焦虑、抑郁、双相情感障碍、强迫症、任何数量的情绪障碍或人格障碍的折磨，但因为他们看起来不符合刻板印象，他们很容易被忽视，不被认为是该群体的一部分。所以，任何形式的刻板印象都会在多方面真正伤害到每个人。就像你不能将经历心理健康问题的人的整个经历抽丝剥茧并概括化一样。你更绝对不能把他们塞进两个桶里的任何一个。要么你是坏的，要么你是悲伤的，就像我说的。所以这真的把我带到了我们是如何被教导去看待抑郁症的，特别是
specifically. Now, let me begin by saying that in order to be diagnosed with depression, you do need to meet certain criteria in the DSM. That's the diagnostic and statistical manual of mental disorders. You know, if you go to a doctor, a psychiatrist, a psychologist, they are going to look for certain things. And there are also a many different, like quite a few different types of depression. I think sometimes we say, oh, someone's depressed and we just think of this general, generic run-of-the-mill depression, but you can have major depressive disorder, persistent depressive disorder, seasonal effective disorder, postpartum depression, depression is also part of bipolar. It's all distressing, like all of them cause, you know, a lot of impairment in some
具体来说。现在，首先我要说的是，为了被诊断为抑郁症，你确实需要满足《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中的某些标准。你知道的，如果你去看医生、精神科医生、心理学家，他们会寻找某些特定的东西。而且也有许多不同的、相当多种不同类型的抑郁症。我想有时我们说，哦，某人抑郁了，我们就会想到这种一般的、常规的抑郁症，但你可能会患有重度抑郁障碍、持续性抑郁障碍、季节性情感障碍、产后抑郁症，抑郁症也是双相情感障碍的一部分。所有这些都令人痛苦，就像所有这些都会在某种程度上导致
form, but mainly what we are looking for, and what a psychiatrist or a psychologist or a doctor, any number of professionals are looking for, is a depressive episode. So they want, to know that at some point you have experienced a prolonged period normally for more than two weeks of having a depressed mood, having diminished interest or pleasure in your hobbies and activities, seeing a change in your weight, in your appetite, insomnia, motor skills may have declined, diminished ability to think or concentrate, you might feel very worthless, very tired, and also you have these recurrent thoughts of death. Not just a fear of dying,
某种形式的严重损害，但主要是我们在寻找的，以及精神科医生、心理学家或医生、任何数量的专业人员在寻找的，是一个抑郁发作。所以他们想要知道，在某个时刻，你是否经历过一段长时间的时期（通常超过两周），表现为情绪低落、对爱好和活动的兴趣或乐趣减退、体重和食欲发生变化、失眠、运动技能可能下降、思考或集中注意力的能力减退、你可能会觉得自己一文不值、非常疲惫，并且你还有这些反复出现的死亡想法。不仅仅是对死亡的恐惧，
although that is part of it, but also a suicidal ideation, a plan, or you have previously attempted. Another thing they are looking for if you want to be diagnosed with depression or a major depressive disorder is that you don't have any manic or hypomanic symptoms. So basically that means that your depressive symptoms
尽管这也是其中的一部分，但还有自杀意念、计划，或者你以前尝试过。如果你想被诊断为抑郁症或重度抑郁障碍，他们寻找的另一件事是，你没有任何躁狂或轻躁狂症状。所以基本上这意味着你的抑郁症状
aren't counterbalanced by a, period afterwards of mania. So elevated mood, increased energy, activity, impulsivity, feelings of grandiosity, that kind of thing. So they want to rule out that you don't have bipolar disorder or some other kind of mood disorder. Now that is a very general and very general understanding of depression. It's definitely not everything you need to know. But there's one of the component here and that is when a professional is looking at the list of criteria, you don't have to meet them all. So I gave you like a list of maybe nine.
并没有被随后的一个时期的躁狂状态所平衡。因此，情绪高涨、能量增加、活动增多、冲动、有夸大感，诸如此类的事情。所以他们想要排除你没有患双相情感障碍或其他类型的情绪障碍。现在这是一个非常普遍且非常笼统的对抑郁症的理解。它绝对不是你需要知道的全部。但这里还有一个组成部分，那就是当专业人员查看标准清单时，你不需要满足所有这些标准。所以我列出了一份大约九项的清单。
You only have to have between two to five to diagnose you with a depressive episode, either a minor or a major depressive episode. So that means that there are almost, and I did by math here, I went back to my economics roots, there are almost 627 different combinations of symptoms that you could have to be diagnosed with depression. So this idea that depression looks one way, yes, we have a big list of symptoms,
你只需要有两到五项就能被诊断为抑郁发作，无论是轻度还是重度抑郁发作。这意味着几乎有，我在这里做过数学计算，我回到了我的经济学根源，几乎有627种不同的症状组合，你可能拥有这些症状从而被诊断为抑郁症。所以这种认为抑郁症只有一种样子的观点，是的，我们有一个长长的症状清单，
but in order to be diagnosed, you only need to have maybe three or four or five. So if we do the combination of them, again, 627 different combinations of symptoms. You could get 10 people in a room who all have depression, and they still might not look the same. Some of them may have a lots of energy, insomnia, a depressed mood,
但为了被诊断，你可能只需要有三、四或五项。所以如果我们把它们组合起来，同样，有627种不同的症状组合。你可以在一个房间里找到10个都患有抑郁症的人，而他们的表现仍然可能完全不同。他们中的一些人可能会有大量的精力、失眠、情绪低落，
but, you know, they're still interested in exercising. They still feel good about themselves. They still eat normally. Then you could have someone who predominantly feels quite worthless and is consistently thinking about death, but they are still able to concentrate and they wouldn't classify themselves as being depressed. If you kind of get where I'm coming from,
但是，你知道的，他们仍然对锻炼感兴趣。他们仍然自我感觉良好。他们仍然正常吃饭。然后你可能会有一个人，他主要感到相当无代价感并且一直在想死的事，但他们仍然能够集中注意力，他们不会把自己归类为抑郁症患者。如果你有点明白我的意思的话，
like there is just so many iterations of this. And with that in mind, it's not just that we have all these combinations, it's that each person's way of expressing a singular symptom is also going to be different. So let's talk about being one that people pull out as markedly diminished interest or pleasure in most or all activities. That is going to look really different for different people.
就像有这么多的表现形式一样。带着这一点，不仅我们有所有这些组合，而且每个人表达单一症状的方式也将是不同的。所以让我们谈谈那个被人们挑选出来作为对大多数或所有活动明显兴趣或乐趣减退的症状。对于不同的人来说，这看起来会非常不同。
For one person, they may no longer find joy in their favorite hobbies like painting or playing music. For another, it could be that they still enjoy their hobbies but they are withdrawing from social gatherings. For someone else, it's that they can't find motivation to do basic things like cooking or shower, but they still find time to be social.
对于一个人来说，他们可能不再从自己喜爱的爱好（如绘画或演奏音乐）中找到乐趣。对另一个人来说，可能是他们仍然喜欢自己的爱好，但他们正在退出社交聚会。对另一个人来说，是他们找不到做饭或洗澡等基本事情的动力，但他们仍然能找到时间进行社交。
So again, each symptom, there will be individual differences. This is why. This is my argument for why. We cannot be led to believe that depression is going to look one certain way on everyone all of the time. The notion of depression as extreme sadness or crying all the time, isolation, staying in bed, a crisis, an inability to function. It does not explain everybody's experience.
所以同样地，每个症状都会有其个体差异。这就是为什么。这就是我的论点，为什么。我们不能被引导去相信抑郁症在所有人的所有时间里都会呈现某种特定的样子。将抑郁症视为极端悲伤或一直哭泣、孤立、呆在床上、处于危机中、无法运作的观念。它并不能解释每个人的经历。
And you know what, there is no shame in your depression looking that way. In fact, for me at times it has looked that way. I talked about that in my episode on my mental breakdown last year. You know, there was a period where my depression presented in a very stereotypical way, but it cannot be the only narrative being told by society. That limited perspective can be harmful because it overlooks the many hidden or subtle ways that depression can show up, like irritability, like perfectionism, overworking physical symptoms that people might confuse with physical ill health or excessive socializing,
你知道吗，你的抑郁症呈现出那种样子并没有什么可耻的。事实上，对我来说，有时它确实呈现出那个样子。我在去年关于我的精神崩溃的那期节目中谈到过这一点。你知道的，曾有一段时间，我的抑郁症以一种非常典型的方式表现出来，但这不能成为社会讲述的唯一叙事。那种局限的视角可能是有害的，因为它忽视了抑郁症可能表现出来的许多隐藏或微妙的方式，比如易怒、完美主义、过度工作、人们可能与身体健康不佳混淆的身体症状或过度社交，
all of these coping mechanisms that aren't typically thought of. So this kind of brings me to what we're talking about today. High functioning depression. Sorry it's taking me so long to get here, but I promise that explanation was worth it. High functioning depression, it's not a medical diagnosis, but it is a form of depression that we can recognize where from the outside someone looks very capable, successful, perfectly happy. They look like they're doing well, but below the surface they are really struggling and they're experiencing a lot of personal or private impairment. It is the kind of depression or depressive
所有这些通常不被认为是应对机制的机制。所以这差不多引出了我们今天谈论的话题。高功能抑郁症。抱歉我花了这么长时间才来到这里，但我保证那个解释是值得的。高功能抑郁症，它不是一个医学诊断，但它是我们可以识别的一种抑郁症形式，从外部看，某人看起来非常能干、成功、非常快乐。他们看起来过得很好，但在表面之下，他们真的在苦苦挣扎，并经历了很多个人或私下的功能损害。它是那种抑郁症或抑郁发作
episode that doesn't meet the stereotype and because of that people sometimes feel like their experience is less valid. Maybe they don't deserve the same level of help as others. Maybe they have been misdiagnosed. But none of this is true. It's just that the reality of their depression is different to what we've been told. Now, I'm going to say this. I do think that the term high functioning depression, it's not the best choice of words. I don't love it all that much.
不符合刻板印象的剧集，正因如此，人们有时会觉得自己的经历不那么正当。也许他们觉得自己不配得到和别人一样多的帮助。也许他们被误诊了。但这些都不是真的。只是他们抑郁的现实与我们被告知的不一样。现在，我要这么说。我确实认为“高功能抑郁”这个词并不是最好的选择。我并不是特别喜欢它。
It's kind of the same reason why I guess people don't like high functioning autism. It's obviously not an official diagnosis. and it almost has the effect of ranking individuals on like some merit base. Like are you worthy and high functioning or are you low functioning and not worthy? Like there is this weird hierarchy to it. It's not inclusive. And it can sometimes be quite misleading. You know, high functioning doesn't mean someone doesn't need support.
这和我想人们不喜欢“高功能自闭症”的原因有点类似。它显然不是一个官方诊断。它几乎起到了按某种功利标准对个人进行等级划分的效果。就像你是高功能、有价值的，还是低功能、没价值的？这其中似乎存在一种奇怪的等级制度。它不具包容性。而且有时可能会相当具有误导性。你知道，高功能并不意味着某人不需要支持。
Here are some other reasons why people are trying to maybe steer us away from the term high functioning depression. It can really minimize the struggle, of course, people with high functioning. functioning depression experience just as much emotional pain, self-doubt and exhaustion, even if from the outside, they're great at masking it. It does, you know, that term does really reinforce a very toxic productivity mindset. Kind of suggests that as long as you are productive, your mental health isn't a problem and you don't need help for it. It also definitely creates a barrier to diagnoses and treatment.
以下是人们试图引导我们远离“高功能抑郁”这个词的其他一些原因。它确实会淡化这种挣扎，当然，患有高功能抑郁的人会经历同样多的情感痛苦、自我怀疑和精疲力竭，即使从外表上看，他们很擅长掩饰。这个词确实强化了一种非常有害的功利心态。它似乎在暗示，只要你有生产力，你的精神健康就不是问题，你也不需要为此寻求帮助。它肯定也为诊断和治疗制造了障碍。
And you know what, depression, whether it's high functioning or low functioning, which that's the part of it that I hate low functioning. Like you still are struggling. And it exists on a spectrum like everything else does. So I actually typically call it something else in my own life, in my day-to-day life, I refer to high-functioning depression as masked depression or disguised depression. Because I just think that that's a better term for it. So what does masked depression or disguised depression look like?
而且你知道吗，抑郁症，无论是高功能的还是低功能的——这也是我讨厌低功能的那部分原因。就像你仍在挣扎一样。它和其他事物一样存在于一个光谱上。所以我在自己的生活中，在日常生活中，通常会用另一个词来称呼它，我将高功能抑郁称为“戴面具的抑郁”（masked depression）或“伪装的抑郁”（disguised depression）。因为我只是觉得这是个更好的词。那么，戴面具的抑郁或伪装的抑郁是什么样的呢？
How does that compare to what we've been told to think about it? I'm going to use my own experience as an example here. I think from the outside, sometimes I have made the mistake of trying too hard to pretend that everything is perfect in my life, either online or with my family and friends, even with my partner. And it's meant that I will truly be in the trenches. I will be thinking terrible, dark thoughts, struggling with zero motivation, wanting to sleep 15 hours a day. And if someone was like, hey, how are you?
这与我们被灌输的想法相比如何？我在这里以我自己的经历为例。我想从外表来看，有时我会犯这样的错误，过于拼命地假装我生活中的一切都是完美的，无论是在网上还是在我的家人和朋友面前，甚至是和我的伴侣在一起。这意味着我将真正处于水深火热之中。我会想着可怕、黑暗的事情，与零动力作斗争，想要一天睡15个小时。如果有人问，嘿，你好吗？
Even like my partner, even like my friends, they'd be like, oh, how are you going? I can be quite dismissive of that question and be like, I'm fine. Like, I'm fine. I'm good. Yep, super, super good. I think mass depression is, wanting to keep up the appearance that your life is okay, either consciously or unconsciously, perhaps unconsciously because, you know, admitting it to other people, allowing the symptoms to be
甚至就像我的伴侣，甚至像我的朋友，他们会问，哦，你最近怎么样？我对这个问题可能会表现得很冷淡，然后说，我很好。就像，我很好。我很好。没错，超级，超级好。我认为戴面具的抑郁，是有意识或无意识地想要保持你生活一切正常的表象，也许是无意识的，因为，你知道，向其他人承认这一点，允许这些症状
visible would mean that you would have to acknowledge it. I think people with mass depression often overwork themselves. They often have a lot on their plate. They often surround themselves with a lot of other high achievers. They put a lot of responsibilities on their plate. They don't take breaks. They push themselves to a point of burnout. And then they also go through a lot more periods of withdrawal. So you just don't see them for a while.
显露出来就意味着你必须承认它。我认为患有戴面具的抑郁的人经常过度工作。他们的生活往往排得满满当当。他们身边通常环绕着许多其他的高成就者。他们在自己的日程上承担了大量的责任。他们不休息。他们把自己逼到了精疲力竭的地步。然后他们还会经历更多的退缩期。所以你有一段时间就是看不到他们。
You know, you can't reach them. You can't access them. All in an effort from them to keep what they're going through quite private. you know, mass depression comes with a lot of unconscious pretenses, probably because we have internalized the stigma surrounding looking depressed and we don't want to be lumped into the sad box, but also because it's meant for me, at least, that a lot of my symptoms impacted things that people normally don't see. So it's easier to conceal. So that's the part of it that's not necessarily conscious. It just kind of happens, you know. It would be hard to know how tired I am. am if you only met me for two hours or we only had dinner once a week because my fatigue is quite a private symptom. Same with like those spiraling negative thought patterns, the thoughts of death, the existential questions, those are hard to see because they're not outward facing because you can't climb into my brain and look around and be like, ugh, yuck, like this is not
你知道，你联系不上他们。你无法接近他们。这一切都是为了让他们所经历的事情保持相当的私密性。你知道，戴面具的抑郁伴随着许多无意识的伪装，可能是因为我们已经内化了围绕着看起来抑郁的耻辱感，我们不想被归入悲伤的行列，但也因为对我而言，至少这意味着我的许多症状影响了人们通常看不到的事情。所以更容易掩盖。所以这就是它不一定是conscious的那部分。它只是某种程度上发生了，你知道的。如果你只跟我见面两个小时，或者我们一周只吃一次晚饭，你很难知道我有多累，因为我的疲劳是一个相当私人的症状。那些盘旋的消极思维模式、对死亡的想法、存在主义的问题也是如此，这些都很难被看到，因为它们不是外向型的，因为你不能爬进我的大脑四处看看，然后说，呃，真恶心，这
good. Like someone needs to clean this up. This is not healthy. Like you can't do that. You know, you can't come into my house and see what a mess it is. And, I invited you. So I think for people with high-functioning depression, yes, there is a sense of like they really feel the need to conceal it, but it may also be that their depression shows up in a much more private manner just by the nature of what symptoms are occurring. People with mass depression,
不好。就像需要有人来清理这个一样。这不健康。就像你不能那样做。你知道，你不能走进我的房子看到它是多么一团糟。而且，我邀请了你。所以我想对于患有高功能抑郁的人来说，是的，有一种感觉，他们真的很觉得需要掩盖它，但这也可能是因为由于症状发生的性质，他们的抑郁以一种更加私密的方式表现出来。患有戴面具抑郁的人，
I also think involve themselves in a lot of very private coping as well. So coping mechanisms that aren't necessarily visible. Emotional eating, relying on alcohol, drinking a whole bottle of wine by themselves at home. social media or again work to numb themselves and that numbness is a huge component of this and I think it's something that once we can step into and once we once we can blunt our emotions numb ourselves to the world it means that we can carry ourselves through truly anything because we don't have to feel our feelings basically we can switch on autopilot and still do all the things that need to be done in order to be accepted and be seen as quite functioning, but also because of that, we're not really
我也认为他们会参与很多非常私密的应对机制。也就是说不一定可见的应对机制。情绪性进食，依赖酒精，独自在家喝掉整瓶酒。社交媒体或者再次通过工作来让自己麻木，而这种麻木是其中的一个巨大组成部分，我认为一旦我们能够踏入其中，一旦我们能够钝化我们的情绪，让自己对世界麻木，这就意味着我们可以度过真正的一切，因为我们基本上不必去感受我们的情绪，我们可以开启自动驾驶模式，依然去做所有需要做的事情，以便被接受并被视为颇具功能性，但也正因为如此，我们并没有真正在
investing in anything deeply. So, you know, you may work really, really hard on some big project. You get amazing feedback. You have amazing results and you still feel empty. Or something great has happened in your life because you've detached from the bad stuff as well and you've numbed yourself to your experiences. It just feels like nothing. Falling in love, for example. You know, you could be dating someone, you're like, wow, this person is incredible. How come I can't commit fully emotionally to this experience, not even to this person, but just to the niceness of falling in love? Someone actually explained this really, really well, and it was a listener who DMed me with a question, and part of her question or her message to me said, it's like I'm looking down into
任何事情上进行深度的投入。所以，你知道，你可能会非常非常努力地完成某个宏大的项目。你得到了惊人的反馈。你取得了惊人的成果，但你仍然感到空虚。或者你的生活中发生了很棒的事情，因为你也从不好的事情中抽离出来了，并且对自己的经历感到了麻木。感觉就像什么都没有。比如坠入爱河。你知道，你可能在和某人约会，你会想，哇，这个人太不可思议了。为什么我不能在情感上完全投入到这段经历中，甚至不是对这个人，而只是对坠入爱河的美好感觉？有人实际上把这一点解释得非常非常好，那是一个给我发私信提问的听众，她的问题或发给我的信息的一部分说，这就好像我在向下俯视
my own life with no emotions, like I'm watching it from above. And that is exactly the perfect description. Like it always reminds me. I don't know if you've seen the Amy Winehouse documentary. Amy Winehouse, of course, had depression herself amongst a litany of other really difficult things. And there's a scene in the documentary, which I love. I love that documentary.
我自己的生活却没有任何情绪，就像我在上面看着它一样。这绝对是完美的描述。就像它总是让我想起。我不知道你有没有看过艾米·怀恩豪斯的纪录片。艾米·怀恩豪斯本人当然也患有抑郁症，除此之外还有一长串非常艰难的事情。纪录片里有一个场景，我很喜欢。我很喜欢那部纪录片。
But she wins a Grammy. And they're filming her. And she looked so excited and stunned. And everyone who loves her is there. and it should be like the highlight of her life and then her friend pulls her aside or she pulls her friend aside something happens and her friend is like oh my god this is so exciting
但她赢得了格莱美奖。他们正在拍摄她。她看起来那么兴奋和震惊。所有爱她的人都在那里。这本该是她生命中的高光时刻，然后她的朋友把她拉到一边，或者她把朋友拉到一边，发生了什么事，她的朋友说，哦，天哪，这太令人兴奋了
and she's just like I feel nothing like I just feel absolutely nothing this should be the best day of my life and I feel nothing and I think that a big part of that is probably an episode of mass depression where she felt like in the moment she needed to be on and be okay but
而她却说，我什么感觉都没有，我只是觉得绝对什么感觉都没有，这本该是我生命中最美好的一天，而我却什么感觉都没有，我认为这其中的很大一部分可能是一阵戴面具的抑郁，她觉得在那一刻她需要表现出来并且表现得很好，但
the moment there was a trusted person there, it was like the mask slipped. So this is what it looks like. Maybe you can see yourself in these descriptions. You can see yourself in the overachiever, the overworker, in the emotional numbness, in the hidden coping mechanisms. I want to talk about why it occurs. You know, besides stigma, besides some of the things we've talked about, what are the contributing factors to mass depression? Well, we are. We are, we are. We are, going to take a short break, a quick decompress for a second, but when we return, we will talk origins and we will, of course, also talk about how to cope. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter,
一旦那里有一个可以信任的人，就好像面具滑落了。这就是它的样子。也许你能在这些描述中看到你自己的影子。你能在那个高成就者、过度工作者、情绪麻木以及隐藏的应对机制中看到自己。我想谈谈它为什么会发生。你知道，除了耻辱感，除了我们讨论过的一些事情之外，导致戴面具的抑郁的因素有哪些？好吧，我们正在。我们正在，我们正在。我们正在，要进行短暂的休息，快速放松一下，但当我们回来时，我们将讨论根源，当然，我们还将讨论如何应对。请继续收听。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，
and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
那是I-Hart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方的“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍打小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在本集节目中，我们在这里挑选它，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在节目里聊可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的一年之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听look back at it。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan, Ryan, part. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different
欢迎来到我的新播客《用难的方式去学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安，瑞安，帕特。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入到追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道我们什么时候才算做得够多。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于胜利和失败。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《用难的方式去学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《用难的方式去学习》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
你对这个特定的测试做了两次手脚，以至于。我对这个测试做了一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, so there are some main explanations for while you may find yourself masking your
我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。好的，所以关于你为什么会发现自己掩盖了
depression or identifying as quote-unquote high functioning. Firstly, a big, big part of it comes down to not just how, but where you were raised. You might have come from a family or culture that teaches people not to talk about mental illness, in which case a form of mass depression, mast anxiety, mast anything, is much more likely. something really interesting I've noticed is the correlation between countries that report low mental illness rates and the rate of stigma. You know, it's most likely that if we went into every single country and we did proper examinations and diagnoses, about a third of people across their lifetime would have mental ill health. That's the kind of accepted rate that people suggest is most likely
抑郁症或自称为所谓的高功能，有一些主要的解释。首先，很大很大一部分原因不仅在于你怎么被抚养长大的，还在于你在哪里被抚养长大的。你可能来自一个家庭或文化，它教导人们不要谈论精神疾病，在这种情况下，戴面具的抑郁、戴面具的焦虑、戴面具的任何事情都更有可能发生。我注意到的一件非常有趣的事情是，报告精神疾病发病率低的国家与污名化程度之间存在相关性。你知道，最有可能是，如果我们进入每一个国家并进行适当的检查和诊断，大约三分之一的人在其一生中都会有心理健康问题。这是人们认为最有可能被普遍接受的比率
if people actually got diagnosed. So when a country or a government is saying, oh, you know, well, mental ill health, the rate of that in our country is one or two percent, I always look at that and I'm like, that means that the rate of masking and high functioning or disguised depression, anxiety, OCD bipolar, whatever it is, is so much higher.
如果人们真的得到了诊断。所以当一个国家或政府说，哦，你知道，嗯，在我们国家心理健康问题的发病率是百分之一或百分之二时，我总是看着它并想，这意味着掩饰以及高功能或伪装的抑郁、焦虑、强迫症、双相情感障碍，无论是什么的比率，要高得多。
And it also means, A, there is probably a lot of stigma in instances that are ignored. B, they probably don't have the infrastructure to even measure mental ill health rates. Or C, the true, you know, The true problem is that it's being deliberately hidden and they don't want to acknowledge it. It's probably a combination of all three. So as a result, if you are living in a country where they're like,
这也意味着，A，在被忽视的情况下可能存在很多污名。B，他们可能甚至没有基础设施来衡量心理健康问题的发病率。或者C，真正的问题是，真实的问题是它被蓄意隐瞒了，他们不想承认这一点。这很可能是所有这三者的结合。因此，结果是，如果你生活在一个国家，他们说，
ah, our rate of depression is 0.1% or 0.5%. The chances of mass depression in a community like that is going to be a lot higher. You may have also developed mass depression if you think you'll feel better by powering through it on your own. Now, where does that come from? I'm sure a lot of you are like screaming into your phone, it comes from childhood. And it does. It comes from being taught that self-sufficiency was the way and your self-sufficiency and independence was rewarded, which is an important thing for a child's development, but it was rewarded
啊，我们的抑郁症发病率是0.1%或0.5%。在这样的社区里，戴面具的抑郁的发病率会高得多。如果你认为通过自己硬挺过去会感觉更好，你可能也已经发展出了戴面具的抑郁。现在，这从何而来？我确信你们很多人都在对着手机尖叫，它来自童年。确实如此。它来自于被教导自给自足是唯一的出路，你的自给自足和独立得到了回报，这对于儿童的发展很重要，但它得到了回报
to an extent that like you were discouraged from showing vulnerability or asking for help. So when you really did need assistance, your parents were like, we're not going to get involved in that. That can really lead to a sense of hyper-independence. i.e. if I can't manage this alone, if I can't do this alone, I'm weak. And this kind of messaging can cause us to minimize our experiences and think, you know, I don't have it as bad as that person does as a way of denial and avoidance. I also think mass depression is more likely if you are trying to avoid any impact of your depression
达到一定程度时，你会觉得表达脆弱或寻求帮助是受阻的。因此，当你真正需要帮助时，你的父母会觉得：我们不会介入这件事。这真的会导致一种高度独立的心理，也就是说，如果我无法独自处理这件事，如果我无法独自做到这一点，我就是软弱的。这种信息会让我们尽量减少自己的经历，并认为“你知道的，我没有那个人那么糟糕”，以此作为一种否认和回避的方式。我还认为，如果你试图回避抑郁症带来的任何影响——
on your job, on your relationships, on your life. and you are hoping that if you just ignore it for long enough, it will lift. This is just a time thing. I think this is basically a fear of losing momentum, a fear of losing progress, which is very common in a success-obsessed society. It's also a fear of losing control. Something I've heard from a lot of people and even some listeners is this fear that if you let yourself acknowledge and feel depressed or,
对你的工作、对你的人际关系、对你的生活的影响，那么你更有可能陷入功能性抑郁。你希望只要忽视它足够长的时间，它就会自己消散，这只是一个时间问题。我认为这基本上是对失去前进动力的恐惧，是对失去进展的恐惧，这在一个痴迷于成功的社会中非常普遍。这也是对失去控制的恐惧。我从很多人甚至一些听众那里听到过的一种恐惧是：如果你让自己承认并感受到抑郁，或者——
admit it to yourself or lean in to the terrible feelings, you are going to lose touch with your reality and you're going to lose touch with your sanity. Basically, we have this fear that if we don't mask our depression to the world and therefore to ourselves, we are going to go, quote unquote, crazy. The thing is, I get this fear. It really, really happens. In fact, you are actually more likely to experience severe symptoms, but again, mostly irreversible symptoms. if you keep suppressing and avoiding what you're going through, because the emotional toll is going to become greater and more strenuous. But I promise you that if you acknowledge it and you look at it in the eyes and you get help,
对自己承认这一点，或者沉浸在可怕的感受中，你将与现实脱节，你将失去理智。基本上，我们有一种恐惧：如果我们不对世界、也就是不对我们自己掩饰我们的抑郁，我们就会变得“发疯”。问题是，我懂这种恐惧。它真的、真的会发生。事实上，如果你继续压抑和回避你所经历的事情，你实际上更有可能经历严重的症状，而且往往是不可逆的症状，因为情绪上的代价会变得越来越大、越来越难以承受。但我向你保证，如果你承认它，正视它，并寻求帮助，
you're not going to lose your sanity, you're not going to lose your mind. And this idea and this fear, I understand it. We all want to feel calm and stable in our lives, but really it does just come back to stigma. And it comes back to that age-old story we've been told, back to the times when most mental illnesses were just labeled hysteria and you were put in an asylum that this experience is terrible and it's going to ruin your life and it's going to make you different and it's just going to cause you harm like that's what we have been led to believe it's going to make you
你不会失去理智，你不会精神崩溃。这种想法和恐惧，我能理解。我们都希望在生活中感到平静和稳定，但说到底，这还是归结于耻辱感。这又回到了我们从小听到的那个老掉牙的故事——回到大多数精神疾病仅仅被称为癔症、而你会被关进精神病院的时代——这种经历是可怕的，它会毁了你的生活，它会让你变得与众不同，它只会给你带来伤害。这就是我们被灌输的观念，它会让你变得——
crazy that's not true let me say this there are so many more treatments more pathways more options for people nowadays there is nothing as well that you will have to go through alone this will not be the first time that a doctor or a psychologist has seen something similar to your case. This is not going to be the first time someone has had to go through what you're going through. And even if the worst, worst, worst case scenario happens, which it won't, but you find yourself losing your sanity, which you won't, you're still going to find a way to come back to yourself. I promise you that. And getting help sooner, accessing your emotion sooner, will, only ever help that. It will never make that worse. But I do think that's a big component of sometimes
疯狂。这不是真的。我要这么说：如今，针对人们的治疗方法、途径和选择要多得多。同样，也没有什么事情是你必须独自经历的。这绝不会是医生或心理学家第一次看到与你的情况类似的事情。这绝不会是第一次有人不得不经历你正在经历的一切。而且，即使发生了最坏、最坏、最坏的情况（虽然不会发生），但你发现自己失去了理智（虽然你不会），你仍然会找到找回自我的方法。我向你保证。更早地寻求帮助，更早地接触你的情绪，只会对这一切有帮助，绝不会让情况变得更糟。但我确实认为，这是有时——
unconsciously masking our depression. We don't want to acknowledge that it could get worse, but by doing that, we allow it to get worse. Sometimes though, mass depression actually just comes from trauma, and it's just expressed that way without any kind of conscious decision to conceal it. So there was an amazing research paper that was published last year, last year, maybe even this year. It was published very recently. It's titled Understanding High Functioning Depression in adults. And in it, they conducted 120 interviews with individuals between 18 and 75 who had been identified as having mass depression. They obviously call it high functioning depression, 20 of whom out of the 120 had extreme high functioning depression to the point where.
无意识地掩饰我们抑郁的一个重要组成部分。我们不想承认情况可能会恶变，但通过这样做，我们却任由情况恶化。不过，有时功能性抑郁实际上只是源于创伤，并且就是这样表现出来的，没有任何掩盖它的有意识决定。因此，去年发表了一篇非常棒的研究论文，可能是去年，甚至可能是今年，它是最近才发表的。它的标题是《理解成年人的高功能抑郁症》（Understanding High Functioning Depression in Adults）。在论文中，他们对120名被认定患有功能性抑郁症、年龄在18岁到75岁之间的个人进行了访谈。他们显然称之为高功能抑郁症，在这120人中，有20人患有极端的高功能抑郁症，以至于——
you know, someone actually had recommended them to the study, they didn't even believe that they had a problem, but it was quite obvious that they did. They found a very, very, very strong correlation between mast or high-functioning depression and trauma. In particular, a lot of these individuals had experienced a lot of compounding minor traumas, but also a lot of big trauma as well, such that, you know, especially if it had occurred at an early age, maybe their brains had begun to process their emotions differently and detach very, very early on from big feelings to protect themselves emotionally. They also found that people with high functioning depression, as they called it, were more
你知道的，有人其实向他们推荐了这项研究，他们甚至不相信自己有什么问题，但很明显他们确实有。他们发现，功能性或高功能抑郁症与创伤之间存在非常、非常、非常强的相关性。特别是，其中许多人经历过许多累积的微小创伤，但也经历过很多重大创伤，以至于，你知道的，特别是如果这些创伤发生在早期，他们的大脑可能已经开始以不同的方式处理情绪，并在很早的时候就与强烈的情感脱钩，从而在情感上保护自己。他们还发现，患有高功能抑郁症（如他们所称）的人更容易——
likely to experience something called anhadonia. This is a lack of pleasure in everyday activities and joys, and they suggested that the higher rates of anadonia in people with high functioning depression might actually be contributing to them, being quite overachievers or pushing themselves because their kind of baseline for experiencing pleasure is so much higher. So more needs to occur, more needs to happen. They need to achieve more success in order to feel the level of pride and enjoyment and pleasure that, you know, someone else would feel from just getting a good job from their boss. Essentially, they need a bigger win. They need to strive and feel much more important. They need a much higher level of
体验到一种叫做“快感缺失”（anhedonia）的东西。这是指在日常活动和乐趣中缺乏快乐，他们认为，高功能抑郁症患者较高的快感缺失率实际上可能促使他们成为过度成就者，或者不断逼迫自己，因为他们体验快乐的基线要高得多。因此，需要发生更多的事情，需要做更多的事情。他们需要取得更多成功，才能感受到那种骄傲、享受和快乐的水平——你知道的，其他人仅仅从老板那里得到一份好工作就能感受到的那种水平。本质上，他们需要更大的胜利。他们需要奋斗，需要觉得自己更重要，需要更高水平的——
success to reach that pleasure threshold that, you know, someone else would reach quite easily. That's the big takeaway. Anadonia and high functioning depression are linked, but also trauma and high functioning depression. So those are a few explanations for why it is that you may be experiencing this type of depression, why it is more common in certain cultures, certain communities, in people who have been raised a certain way. Now I want to talk about what we're going to do about it. We have this experience, we're living this experience. What do we do?
成功，才能达到其他人可以相当轻松地达到的快乐门槛。这就是最大的收获。快感缺失与高功能抑郁症息息相关，创伤与高功能抑郁症也息息相关。这些就是为什么你可能会经历这种类型的抑郁症、为什么它在某些文化、某些社区以及以某种方式抚养长大的人群中更常见的一些解释。现在我想谈谈我们该如何应对。我们有这种经历，我们正在经历这种生活。我们该怎么办？
I want to start out by just firstly having a little heart to heart here, you know, between you and me and acknowledging, okay, this is something you are experiencing and you're going through and which you have to manage day in and day out, regardless of whether other people are seeing it or not. I think I know the kind of person you probably are, and I know that you're probably putting on such a brave face, and I know how hard you're trying, and I know you have to give 150% where everyone else might only have to give 50, and I know you must be so tired. I know how hard it is. I also know you probably go back and forth over whether you deserve to have the label and receive support.
我想首先在这里进行一次小小的敞开心扉的交流，你知道的，在你我之间，并承认：好吧，这是你正在经历的、正在经历的、并且无论别人是否看到都必须日复一日去应对的事情。我想我大概知道你是什么样的人，我也知道你可能在强颜欢笑，我知道你有多努力，我知道当其他人只需要付出50%时，你却不得不付出150%，而且我知道你一定累坏了。我知道这有多难。我也知道，你可能在自己是否配得上这个标签并获得支持的问题上反复权衡——
you probably go back and forth over whether this is even real because you're trying to perhaps convince yourself it's not. And I know you are trying so hard. I know you are trying to keep up appearances. I just want to validate that experience for you because it's so freaking hard and tough. And it's exhausting. It's frustrating. But it also doesn't have to continue to be invisible.
你可能在纠结这是否真实，因为你可能正试图说服自己这不是真的。我知道你一直在拼命努力。我知道你正在努力维持表象。我只想为你这种经历提供心理正名（validate），因为这实在太该死地艰难和严酷了。这让人筋疲力尽，令人沮丧。但这并不意味着它必须继续隐形下去。
I think once we acknowledge, okay, just because my depression is high functioning doesn't mean it doesn't exist. That's the first step I think the next step after that is being prepared to talk to others about this. Literally, you could just send them this episode if you want to and just say, hey, you know, all those things I've been struggling with, I think it's this, this explains it well. You can also just start being honest with your family, your closest friends, your partner when they ask you, how are you? How are you going? what would it feel like to just finally say, you know what, not good?
我认为，一旦我们承认：“好吧，仅仅因为我的抑郁是高功能的，并不意味着它不存在。”这是第一步。我认为接下来的下一步是准备好与他人谈论这件事。字面意义上，如果你愿意，你可以直接把这一集发给他们，然后说：“嘿，你知道的，我一直在挣扎的所有这些事情，我认为就是这个，这解释得很好。”你也可以开始对你的家人、你最亲密的朋友、你的伴侣保持诚实，当他们问你“你最近怎么样？你过得好吗？”时，
And I'm hurting and this is hard and can you please help me? What would that feel like? Something that completely changed how I think about asking for help was someone said to me once, your loved ones actually want the opportunity to love you. You are giving them the gift of being able to show you how much they care. Like that's an honor to them. That's a gift. That's an opportunity.
如果只是终于说出“你知道吗，我不好，我在受伤，这很难，你能帮帮我吗？”会是什么感觉？那种感觉会是怎样的？有一次有人对我说的一句话，彻底改变了我对寻求帮助的看法：你爱的人其实渴望有机会去爱。你给了他们一个向你展示他们有多在乎你的机会。这就像是对他们的荣誉，这是一份礼物，这是一个机会。
And I thought about the people in my life who I love and how I love being given the opportunity to show them that I would do anything for them. Like that's actually a real privilege to have that trust. And it's a gift. You know, invite people into your hard moments. Keep them in the loop with your hard days. When they offer to help you, just try out saying yes, see how it feels. think about all the times that you've said yes for others.
我想到了我生命中我爱的人，以及我多么喜欢有机会向他们展示我会为他们做任何事。这其实是一种拥有这种信任的真正特权。这是一份礼物。你知道的，邀请人们进入你艰难的时刻。让他们了解你艰难的日子。当他们主动提出帮忙时，试着说“好”，看看感觉如何。想想你曾经对别人说过多少次“好”——
You know, you've paid your dues. You do so much for other people. It's okay to accept some help back. In fact, I think you might really deserve it. Actually, why did I even say, I think, I know you really deserve it. You've spent so long proving that you don't, that you can do it yourself. We know that now. Like, we know that you are capable.
你知道的，你已经尽过义务了。你为别人做了那么多。接受一些回报的帮助是可以的。事实上，我想你可能真的配得上。其实，我为什么要说“我想”，我知道你真的配得上。你花了那么长时间来证明你不需要，证明你可以自己搞定。我们现在知道了，就像，我们知道你是能干的。我们知道，如果没有人帮你，你也会过得很好。
We know that if no one helped you, you would be fine. But is that really the way that you want to be? Is that the way you want to live? Is that the only option? You know, it's a strange thing to rewire your mind, to accept help, and to let people in after so many years of trying to prove to yourself that you didn't need to do that. But it is so liberating to just have someone see you for what you're really experiencing and to want to love you and help you.
但这就是你真正想要的生活方式吗？这就是你想过的生活吗？这就是唯一的选择吗？你知道的，在经历了多年试图向自己证明你不需要这样做之后，重新布线你的思维去接受帮助并让别人走进来，是一件很奇怪的事情。但让某人真正看到你所经历的真实状态，并且想要爱你、帮助你，是如此令人解放。
And it is like anything else with practice, it gets easier, you get better at it, it becomes more second nature to you. You know, sometimes, and we do need to acknowledge this, we aren't always going to be met with acceptance, and that's when the real battle begins, right? You have opened up, it's taken you so much to kind of pull back the mask and you're shut down. I want to say if that is the case, and you are thinking, you know, it would have been better if I just kept this inside and, you know, if I just made everyone else comfortable and didn't bother them, this is where I really want you to pause.
就像其他事情一样，通过练习，它会变得更容易，你会做得更好，它会变得更像你的第二天性。你知道的，有时——我们需要承认这一点——我们并不总能遇到理解和接受，而真正的战斗就在那时开始了，对吧？你已经敞开心扉，你花了好大力气才拉开面具，结果却被拒绝了。我想说，如果是这样的话，如果你在想：“你知道吗，如果我把这一切藏在心里，让其他所有人都舒服、不去打扰他们，那会更好。”这就是我真正希望你暂停的地方。
You cannot spend your entire life trying to make everyone else's life easier and more comfortable, especially when it makes it harder for you. You just simply cannot. You know, the stigma they are feeling is an issue for them. And it doesn't change your experience. Sometimes I also find these people who are so readily quick to deny, your experience and to say, well, you're not depressed. You're fine. You know, you're okay.
你不能把整个人生都花在试图让每个人的生活都更轻松、更舒适上，尤其是当这让你的生活变得更艰难的时候。你简直不能这样做。你知道的，他们感受到的耻辱是他们自己的问题，这并不能改变你的经历。有时我也发现，这些人如此迅速地否认你的经历，并说“噢，你没有抑郁，你很好，你知道的，你没事”，
I often think these are the people who are lying to themselves as well. Because they're looking at you and they're saying, well, if that person isn't fine, what about all these things I've been trying to hide? What about all these secret parts of me that I have suppressed for so long as well? I think often our openness challenges people to recognize what their closed-offness has cost them. in these instances though i think it's not worth waiting for someone to change their mind that might sound brutal it's not worth waiting to convince someone of your existence of your reality and how you're experiencing the world please in this like very vulnerable period focus on those who bring you up with total acceptance focus on the people for whom if you said i'm having a really bad day they'd say
我经常认为这些人其实也在自欺欺人。因为他们在看着你，然后说：“好吧，如果那个人不正常，那我为了掩饰这些尝试过的一切该怎么办？我长期以来一直压抑的那些秘密部分该怎么办？”我认为，我们的公开往往挑战了人们去认识到他们的封闭让他们付出了什么代价。不过在这些情况下，我认为不值得去等待某人改变主意。这听起来可能很残酷，但为了向别人证明你的存在、你的现实以及你如何体验这个世界，去说服他们是不值得的。请在这个非常脆弱的时期，专注于那些以完全的接受来提升你的人，专注于那些如果你对他们说“我今天过得很糟糕”，他们会说——
i'm coming over or they'd say i see you i feel you i'm sorry i also want you to challenge yourself to prioritize rest without guilt because chances are you're overfunctioning and your acts of trying to compensate for how you feel through success and overworking are probably taking even more of a mental toll so i need something from you i need you to schedule a day or a weekend of nothing i need you to make that a practice you know i'm sure if i set any other kind of goal for you you would meet it really, really quickly. Your goal here is to rest. It's to not be productive.
“我这就过去”或者会说“我懂你，我感同身受，我很抱歉”的人。我还希望你挑战自己去进行不带内疚感的休息，因为很有可能是你在过度运转，而你试图通过成功和过度工作来弥补你感受到的情绪的那些行为，可能正在造成更大的精神消耗。所以我需要你做一件事：我需要你安排一天或一个周末什么也不做。我需要你把这变成一种习惯。你知道的，我确信如果我为你设定任何其他类型的目标，你都会非常非常快地达成。你这里的目标就是休息，就是不要富有成效。
I need you to put effort into this. I need you to be switching off by 8pm at the latest from work, from your responsibilities, from your phone. I need you to take your sick leave. Something I always say to people is that sick leave, you have earned that. That is part of your wage. That is part of your salary. Like sick leave is deducted from your.
我需要你在这上面投入精力。我需要你在最晚晚上8点前切断工作、切断责任、切断手机。我需要你休病假。我总是对人们说的一件事是，病假是你应得的。那是你工资的一部分。那是你薪水的一部分。就像病假是从你的——
total salary that they expected to pay you and put into a separate account, basically, that's how I see it. You still have access and rights to that money. So you need to take your sick leave. You need to slow down for just a second. You know, your worth and personality does not only come from how productive you can be or efficient. Like, we know you can be productive. I know you can be productive. I know you're a high achiever. Rest is an essential part in keeping you well as well. And in keeping you alive. And if it helps you in any way, it's also an important part in keeping you productive, if we really want to go that far. In fact, if you are focused on success and that's something that's really important to you, which I'm assuming it is, people who allow themselves rest and
他们原本预期支付给你的总薪水中扣除，并基本上存入一个单独的账户，我是这么看的。你仍然拥有使用和获得这笔钱的权利。所以你需要休病假。你需要放慢脚步，哪怕只是一秒钟。你知道的，你的价值和个性并非仅仅来自于你能变得多么富有成效或高效。就像，我们知道你能有成效。我知道你能有成效。我知道你是个追求卓越的人。休息是保持健康的重要组成部分，也是保持你活力的重要组成部分。如果这能在任何方面对你有所帮助，它也是让你保持高效的重要组成部分，如果我们真要讨论到那一步的话。事实上，如果你专注于成功，而这对你来说真的很重要（我假设确实如此），那些让自己休息并——
who give themselves downtime only come back better than ever. Let's give some examples here. Simone Biles, Serena Williams, Adele, you know, she took a five-year break from her singing, career and came back with one of her best albums ever. Now no one is going to look at those women and say, God, like she really hasn't done much with her time. Like she's such a failure because she took time for herself and she rested. No, like these women are like at the top of their game. These women and people in general, there are so many more examples. They restored their bodies. They restored their minds and they came back better and stronger than ever. And that's what I need from you. need more examples of this in the age we're in. You know, we need to get rid of this hustle mentality
给自己停机时间的人，只会以比以往更好的状态回归。让我们举几个例子。碧昂丝（Simone Biles，注：此处原播客主播将体操运动员Simone Biles和网球运动员Serena Williams名字及歌手Adele混在了一起，译文保持原意）、小威廉姆斯（Serena Williams）、阿黛尔（Adele），你知道的，她从歌唱事业中休息了五年，回归时带着她有史以来最好的专辑之一。现在没有人会看着这些女性说：“天哪，她真的没有用她的时间做多少事，她是个失败者，因为她花时间照顾自己并休息了。”不，这些女性正处于她们领域的巅峰。这些女性以及一般人——还有更多的例子。她们恢复了身体，恢复了精神，然后以比以往更好、更强的姿态回归。这就是我需要你做到的。在我们身处的时代，我们需要更多这样的例子。我们需要摆脱这种“内卷/拼命”的心态——
which serves no one and focus on how you are going to last the distance, how you are going to ease up on yourself, how you are going to take care of yourself and be present. There is no point working extremely hard for something if by the time you get there, you are ready to collapse and you cannot even appreciate it. Following up from that, in terms of advice for people with high functioning depression. I also saw an amazing piece of advice from a psychiatrist in a recent school of psychology article that spoke about how people with mass depression actually really benefit from breaking out of their routine and not just prioritizing rest, of course, but also going on these microadventures.
这种心态对任何人都没有好处，我们要专注于你如何才能持久、如何才能对自己放宽要求、如何才能照顾好自己并保持当下。如果你到达终点时已经精疲力竭、甚至无法去欣赏它，那么为之付出极其艰辛的努力就毫无意义。在此之后，关于给高功能抑郁症患者的建议，我还看到了一位精神病学家在最近一篇心理学学校文章中提出的一个绝妙建议：患有功能性抑郁症的人实际上非常受益于打破常规，不仅当然要优先考虑休息，还要去进行这些“微冒险”。
And this researcher was looking at the initiation and addition of novelty into the life. to people with depression and how that really improved their well-being. So going on these little adventures, not big things, not solo traveling, not large-scale Europe holidays or Asia holidays or whatever, but just small everyday things was really, really amazing for their well-being and really broke up the monotonous nature of their lives. And what she was saying in this article is that people with mass depression, they often find a lot of solace in their routine because it allows them to further slip. into autopilot mode, but it also becomes really restrictive and secretly quite exhausting.
这位研究人员一直在研究将新奇事物引入并加入抑郁症患者的生活中，以及这如何真正改善了他们的福祉。因此，进行这些小冒险——不是什么大不了的事，不是独自旅行，不是大规模的欧洲假期或亚洲假期之类的，而只是日常的小事情——对他们的福祉真的非常、非常棒，并且真正打破了他们生活的单调乏味。她在文章中指出，功能性抑郁症患者经常在他们的常规中找到很多慰藉，因为这让他们能够进一步滑入——
So allowing yourself planned time to go explore is so important. Like go to a, go strawberry picking. I did that this weekend. I made, it was so much fun. It cost like $10. Like go strawberry picking. Go on a weekend hike. Go walk some foster dogs.
自动驾驶模式，但这同时也变得非常具有限制性，并且私底下让人精疲力竭。因此，给自己安排时间去探索是如此重要。比如去，去摘草莓。我这个周末就去了。我做了，这太有趣了。只花了大约10美元。比如去摘草莓，去周末远足，去遛寄养犬。
Like I have a foster dog right now called Talu. And like she has changed my life in terms of getting out of the house, exploring. my neighborhood, meeting new people, have a gallery day, have a picnic, just drive however long it takes to get to the beach. I guess I live in Australia, so it's not that long, but, you know, go to a beautiful body of water and submerge yourself in it, explore your city. I really think that micro-adventures are so fantastic because novelty for depression in general is fantastic. depression by nature is quite limiting and it keeps things very small and less vibrant and restrictive. So to counteract that, you need to give your mind opportunities to see that things are quite expensive and quite wide and that there is beauty outside of your routine and your desire to appear okay.
就像我现在有一只名叫塔露（Talu）的寄养犬。她改变了我的生活，让我走出家门，探索我的社区，结识新朋友。去过画廊日，去野餐，只要开着车去海边，花多长时间都行。我想我住在澳大利亚，所以其实没那么久，但你知道的，去一个美丽的水体并沉浸其中，探索你的城市。我真的认为微冒险太棒了，因为对抑郁症患者来说，新鲜感通常是极好的。抑郁症本质上是非常局限的，它让事情变得非常渺小、不那么充满活力且具有限制性。因此，为了对抗这一点，你需要给你的思维提供机会，去看到事物其实非常广阔、非常辽阔，并且在你的常规以及你想要表现得“没问题”的愿望之外，还有美景存在。
Like you have to put yourself into these new environments, watch yourself grow, what yourself experience. life and joy and beauty and see how like you come back from those days and just feel so enriched. If you want, you know, more general tips for managing depression, not specifically master depression, I do have an entire episode called, Let's Talk About Depression, very aptly titled, that I think would be super, super useful. And I would direct you to go listen to that because it's just, there's so much more information in there. But for now, we are actually going to take another short break. and when we return, we have everyone's favorite segment, our listener questions,
就像你必须让自己置身于这些全新的环境中，看着自己成长，看着自己体验生活、喜悦和美丽，然后看看自己如何从那些日子里走出来，并感到内心无比充实。如果你想要一些关于应对抑郁症的更一般的建议，而不是专门针对掩饰性抑郁症的，我确实有一整期名为《我们来谈谈抑郁症》（这个名字非常贴切）的节目，我认为那会非常非常有用。我会建议你去听听那一期，因为里面有太多更多的好信息了。但现在，我们要稍事休息一下，等我们回来时，将迎来大家最喜爱的环节——我们的听众提问，
including some questions from you all on how to take care of a partner with mass depression, high functioning burnout, how it shows up in relationships, and how to get yourself to act when you know what you should be doing. So all of that and more very, very shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
其中包含大家提出的一些问题，比如如何照顾患有掩饰性抑郁症、高功能职业倦怠的伴侣，它如何在亲密关系中表现出来，以及当你知道自己该做什么时，如何让自己真正付诸行动。所以，所有这些以及更多内容，很快就会揭晓。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side,
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端迎来一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 颁奖典礼上轻拍小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说小布什不喜欢黑人时。
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我知道你在想什么。这他妈的小布什跟小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个热点，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush I gotta do a little kill. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）可卡因。需要澄清的是，84 年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在节目里聊聊快克，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，说到这儿，马克，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿的线索了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。现在你把那句话说完了。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence.
是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我十多年来在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的有特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，而我们却依然在盲目追逐。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你害怕。
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
因为那是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《吃一堑长一智》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真正的对话。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid.
打开你免费的 IHeart Radio 应用程序。搜索《吃一堑长一智》并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一群网络侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿斯莱比安、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以我们一直在试运行这个新板块。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian, Michael Marantini.
在这个播客板块中，我们邀请听众在 Instagram 上发送具体问题。你可以关注我的账号 @thatpsychology podcast。我一直很喜欢这个板块。我想你们大家也很喜欢它。你知道，我认为这让人们能够真正提出他们感兴趣的问题，并提出更多小众的问题。显然，播客节目中我们确实试图进行详细和深入的探讨。但如果你根据自己正在经历的事情有具体的问题，
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So we've been trialing out this new section.
或者你在社区中看到的情况，亦或是一些独特的研究成果，那么这些内容就显得相当笼统。就像我喜欢能够在节目中回答这些问题，而不是等到事后才来收集你们的反馈。当然，这还处于早期阶段。所以如果你喜欢它，或者不喜欢它，请在下面的评论中告诉我。如果，你知道，每个人都说，好吧，我们不喜欢听众提问。我们不需要这些了。我们当然会停下来。
of the podcast where we invite listeners to send in specific questions on Instagram. You can follow me at that psychology podcast. And I've been loving it. I think you guys have been enjoying it as well. You know, I think it allows people to really ask the questions that they're interested in and ask more niche questions. Obviously, the podcast episodes, we do try and go into detail and in depth. But it is quite general if you have specific questions based on what you're going through,
但我希望你们会喜欢它。所以知道这一点的唯一方法就是你们告诉我。所以我很想听听你们对这个环节的看法。不过闲话少说，让我们来聊聊这周收到的问题，因为它们太棒了，而且还围绕着一些非常棒的主题。所以我选择的第一个问题来自一位听众，他问：交往三年的男友向我吐露他患有抑郁症，这些年来我确实也看到了迹象，但他对此非常保密，总是强颜欢笑。他也很成功，在金融行业工作，
or what you're seeing in your community or just some like unique piece of research. Like I love to be able to answer that in the show rather than waiting until afterwards to get your feedback. But of course, this is still in the early days. So if you like it, if you don't like it, please let me know in the comments below. If, you know, everyone says, okay, we don't like the listener questions. We're done with those. We will, of course, stop.
他有很多朋友，还踢五人制足球和进行其他运动，但当他陷入挣扎时，他会退缩，甚至对我也是如此。我该如何帮助他？首先，我要承认，成为患有掩饰性抑郁症的人的伴侣在情感上可能会非常困难和痛苦。这并不是因为那个人有什么问题，而是因为我知道，如果你可以的话，你愿意做任何事来带走那种痛苦。
But I'm hoping that you are enjoying it. So the only way to know is if you tell me. So I'd love to hear what you think. about this segment. Without further ado though, let's talk about the questions that we got this week because they were so fantastic and they also followed some really amazing themes. So the first question I chose came from a listener asking, my boyfriend of three years confided in me that he has depression and I've definitely seen signs over the years but he is very secretive about it and keeps a brave face. He's also quite successful and he works in finance,
我懂的。我知道你内心深处渴望在各个方面帮助他，你也只想了解他正在经历的事情。就像如果你知道发生了什么，你愿意去打任何一场仗一样。但对于患有掩饰性抑郁症的人来说，很难向他人敞开心扉，并不是因为，你知道的，他们不喜欢你、不爱你，也不是因为他们不想，
and he has a lot of friends and plays footsil and sport, but when he's struggling, he withdraws, even from me. How do I help him? Let me firstly acknowledge that being the partner of someone with masked depression can be very emotionally difficult and distressing. Not because there's anything wrong with that person, but because I know that if you could, you would do anything to take that pain away.
而是因为他们太习惯于照顾自己，并把事情藏得非常非常深。我知道在表面上，看起来他们把你关在门外，不信任你。我向你保证，事实并非如此。事实上，我认为他们只是不想让你承担任何痛苦。就像，他们也在努力不给你增加负担一样。
I know that. I know that you want to help them in every fibre of your being, and you also just want to understand what they're experiencing. Like you would fight any battle if you knew what was going on. But for people with mass depression, it's very hard to let others in, not because, you know, they don't like you, they don't love you, not because they don't want to,
作为我这种情况下的伴侣，我能给出的最大建议就是，在他们没有要求你做的情况下，做一些能让他们的生活更轻松的事情。所以不要问：你想让我帮你洗衣服吗？不要问：你今晚想让我做饭吗？你想让我整理那个你一直拖延的事情吗？不要给他们说“不”的选项，因为他们总是会说“不”，因为他们不想麻烦你。直接为他们做好。你知道，他们不会主动寻求帮助，但他们内心深处其实还是想要并需要的。
but because they're so used to taking care of themselves and keeping it very, very private. And I know on the outside, it looks like they're shutting you out and they don't trust you. I promise that's not the case. In fact, I think they just, don't want you to take on any of the pain. Like, they're trying not to burden you as well.
现在，这并不意味着你在为他们解决问题。这并不意味着你需要成为他们的看护者。只是做一些你能看到真正给他们造成压力的微小事情。他们不会去，就像他们不会要求你替他们做一样。主动采取行动，在你觉得有能力的地方介入。我也非常鼓励你和你的伴侣做一些有趣的事情，即使有时他们可能并不想做。
The biggest recommendation I would have as someone who is the partner in my situation is to just do things without having them ask you to do them that will make their life easier. So don't ask, do you want me to do your laundry for you? Don't ask, do you want me to cook tonight? Do you want me to organize that thing you've been putting off? don't give them the option to say no because they will always say no because they don't want to bother you. Just do it for them. You know, they're not going to ask for help, but they secretly do kind of want it and need it.
你知道的，当他们最终到场时，即使当时觉得筋疲力尽，他们也会感到高兴。为他们计划那些微型冒险。约他们出去约会，你知道的，用野餐或其他有趣的事情给他们一个惊喜。我的男友就为我这样做，这对我激发对生活的热情非常有帮助，因为，你知道的，这是一个惊喜。我并不总是拥有自己规划这些事情的心理精力。然后我就可以和我世界上最喜欢的人一起去做了。
Now, it doesn't mean that you're fixing things for them. It doesn't need that you need to become their caretaker. Just small things that you can see are really like causing them stress. They're not going, like they're not going to ask you to do it for them. Just take the initiative and step. step in where you feel capable. I'd also really encourage you to do fun things with your partner, even if sometimes they don't want to do them.
这太不可思议了。我的最后一个建议是，希望这个建议不用多说，但我还是要说：请照顾好你自己。你知道的，你不需要为他们做所有事情。你不需要找到一个解决方案。你也不需要奉献出自己的每一部分来确保他们没事。归根结底，我知道人们，
You know, they'll be happy when they finally, like when they're there, even if they feel exhausted in the moment. Plan those microadventures for them. Ask them on a date, you know, surprise them with a picnic or something fun. And my boyfriend does this for me and it's so helpful in making me feel excited by my life because, you know, it's a surprise. I don't always have the mental energy to plan these things myself. And then I just get to do it with my favorite person in the world.
这里会有人不同意我的观点，但你确实是第一位的。在任何情况下，你都是第一位的。你应该把你自己放在首位。所以腾出空间是没有问题的。表达你的需求也是没有问题的，即使感觉他们的精神负担比你更大或更有价值。事实并非如此。就像你也有自己的需求和挣扎，理应得到重视。所以这是今天节目的第二个问题。你如何区分长期的、高功能的或掩饰性抑郁症与单纯的职业倦怠？这个问题很棘手。老实说，我觉得它们有时感觉起来很相似。
And it's so incredible. My final tip as well, and this one, I hope, hopefully it goes without saying, but I am going to say it anyways. Please take care of yourself. You know, you don't need to do everything for them. You don't need to find a solution. You also don't need to give every part of yourself to make sure they're okay. At the end of the day, and I know people,
你甚至可能同时经历这两者，因为倦怠不仅是身体上的，也是心理和情感上的，它实际上会导致抑郁状态或引发抑郁发作。我认为区分它们的最大方法是你经历的是精疲力竭还是缺乏兴趣，以及这种精疲力竭是否伴随着持续不断的悲伤。所以在面对倦怠时，通常的感觉就像是你太累了以至于什么也做不了，但你内心深处某种程度上还是想做，也某种程度上想要这个机会。但是，你知道的，对于抑郁症来说，就像是，是的，你筋疲力尽，因为你
People will disagree with me here, but you do come first. In every situation, you do come first. You should be your own first priority. So it's okay to take space. It's okay to also communicate your needs, even if it feels like their mental burden is bigger or more worthwhile than yours. That's not the case. Like you also have needs and have struggles of your own that deserve to be appreciated. So here is question two for today's episode. How can you tell the difference between? long-term high-functioning or mass depression and just being burnt out. This one is tricky. Honestly, I think they sometimes feel the same at times.
精神上被掏空了，但你有时甚至连欲望都没有了，比如你完全没有欲望去做那些你通常想做的事情。你没有欲望变得更有动力。你没有欲望去，你知道的，进行社交，但在倦怠时，你会想：我真的很希望我能做那些事情。我只是做不到。这里有一些很好的问题可以帮助区分它们。那么，休息一下后你感觉好点了吗？如果是，那很可能是倦怠。这种情况持续了数月甚至数年吗，即使你的日常生活发生了变化？如果是，那很可能是掩饰性抑郁症。而且，即使你没有精力，你仍然在乎事物吗？如果是，那是倦怠。
You could even have both at the same time because burnout isn't just physical, it's mental and emotional as well, and it can actually lead to a depressed state or trigger a depressive episode. I think the biggest way to tell the difference is whether it's exhaustion or a lack of interest that you're experiencing and whether the, exhaustion is being met with consistent persistent sadness. So with burnout, it's often like you're just so tired that you can't do anything, but you still kind of want to and you still kind of want the opportunity. But, you know, with depression, it's like, yes, you're exhausted because you're
你对曾经热爱的事物感到冷漠吗？如果是，那是掩饰性抑郁症。我也认为，你知道的，照顾好自己的方式对这两者来说是相似的。所以你可能会发现，仅仅对其中一项采取行动就可以消除另一项或提供帮助。所以你并不总是需要立即知道这是职业倦怠还是抑郁症。主要的任务是休息，摆脱那些让你感到压力的事情或额外的责任。
mentally drained, but you also have no desire sometimes to even, like you have no desire to do the things that you would normally want to do. You have no desire to become more motivated. You have no desire to, you know, be social, but with burnout, you're like, I really wish I could do those things. I just can't. Here are some good questions as well to tell the difference. So, do you feel better after a break? If yes, that's probably burnout. Has this lasted for months or years, even with changes in a routine, in your routine? If yes, that's probably mass depression. And, and Do you still care about things even if you don't have energy? If yes, burnout.
减轻任务负担、寻求帮助并对自己宽容一些，无论你处于什么情况，这都是一样的。所以，是的，就这样去处理它。好吧，我们今天的最后一个问题。我知道我有高功能抑郁症，我也知道我需要做什么才能感觉好点并达到更好的状态，但我就是无法让自己去这样做。当我的所有精力都用来维持生计时，我该如何激励自己？首先，听到你这样说我很难过。我知道，当你生活中的其他每个领域都把自己逼得那么紧时，这一定让你感到非常沮丧。
Do you feel indifferent to things that you once loved? If yes, mast depression. I also think, you know, taking care of yourself will be similar for both of these things. So you might find that just acting on one may eliminate the other or may help. So you don't always need to know whether it's burnout or depression immediately. The main things of getting rest. of pulling back from things that are stressing you out or additional responsibilities. The main objective of offloading tasks and asking for help and going easy on yourself,
你是否对曾经热爱的事物感到冷漠？如果是的话，可能伴随着抑郁。我也认为，你知道，照顾好自己对于这两者是相似的。所以你可能会发现，仅仅采取其中一种行动就可能消除另一种，或者会有所帮助。因此，你并不总是需要立即弄清楚它是倦怠还是抑郁。最主要的事情是休息，从让你感到压力的事情或额外的责任中抽身出来。卸载任务、寻求帮助以及对自己放轻松的主要目标，
like that's going to be the same regardless of what situation you're in. So, yeah, approach that way. Okay, our final question for the day. I know I have high functioning depression and I know what I need to do to feel better and get to a better place, but I can't bring myself to do it. how do I motivate myself when all my energy is going to just trying to stay afloat? Firstly, I'm so sorry you're feeling this way. I know it must be so frustrating for you when you push yourself so hard in every other area of your life.
无论你处于什么情况，这都是一样的。所以，是的，用这种方式去处理。好的，我们今天的最后一个问题。我知道我有高功能抑郁症，我也知道我需要做什么才能感觉好点并到达一个更好的状态，但我就是无法强迫自己去做。当我的所有精力都用来维持生计时，我该如何激励自己？首先，听到你这种感受我很难过。我知道当你把自己在生活的其他各个方面都逼得那么紧时，你一定感到非常沮丧。
And it can feel very hopeless when it comes to this very big hurdle. The best thing I can recommend you do that's worked for me is to just pick one thing at a time to improve. If you are an overachiever, we tend to pull. everything on the list, right? You know, we acknowledge, okay, I have depression, I'm feeling terrible, I need to act on this, and if I have to act, I have to do a million things right now to change my life, to change my attitude, to feel better, to get help. That can lead you to feel very overwhelmed because your perfectionism kicks in. You know, if I can't do all of it, I should do none of it. And you get overwhelmed by where to start because everything is suddenly equally
面对这样一个巨大的难题，可能会让人觉得非常绝望。我能给你的最好建议、也是对我最管用的方法，就是一次只挑一件事来改进。如果你是个追求完美的人，我们往往会把清单上的所有事情都揽过来，对吧？你知道的，我们承认，好吧，我有抑郁症，我感觉糟透了，我需要采取行动；既然要行动，我立刻就得做上百万件事来改变生活、改变态度、感觉好点、寻求帮助。这会让你感到不知所措，因为你的完美主义开始作祟了。你知道的，如果我不能把所有事都做好，那我索性什么都不做。你会因为不知道从哪里开始而感到不知所措，因为突然之间所有事情都变得同样重要。
important. So what we need to focus on is just one change for every two weeks. So the first two weeks, I just want you to focus on, okay, I'm going to put all my energy, the limited energy I have to seeing a doctor who's going to help me find a therapist in that second chapter. And then after that, my next task is going to be reaching out. And I'm going to give myself a couple of days, a couple of weeks to do that so I don't feel overwhelmed. Then when I'm ready, I'm going to start implementing behavioral changes. When I'm ready, I'm going to start booking appointments, then I'm going to start journaling once a week. But we are going slow. We are making small incremental changes that tend to snowball into much bigger results. So just seeing your life as the next two weeks,
所以我们需要关注的，只是每两周做出一个改变。所以前两周，我只希望你专注于，好吧，我要把所有的精力——我那有限的精力——都花在去看医生上，医生会帮我在第二阶段找到一个治疗师。在那之后，我的下一个任务就是主动联系。我会给自己几天、几周的时间来做这件事，这样我就不会感到不知所措。然后，当我准备好的时候，我就会开始实施行为上的改变。当我准备好的时候，我就会开始预约，然后我开始每周写一次日记。但我们要放慢脚步。我们在做微小的、渐进式的改变，而这些改变往往会像滚雪球一样带来更大的成果。所以，只要把你的生活看作是接下来的两周，
what can you do in the next two weeks that are going to make you feel better in the moment? You don't have to think about the long term. You don't have to be obsessed with curate, yourself or getting everything done, I just want you to focus on one thing at a time and just don't overwhelm yourself and you will get there slowly and surely. So I think this is all we have time for today. I know it's been a long episode, so thank you if you have made it this far. You guys know I always love to drop a little emoji hint for the loyal listeners amongst you who get to this point. So today, I want you to leave an emoji of your favorite animal. I don't know why I chose that. It just seems fun. It seems appropriate. It seems a little bit lighthearted, uh, given how heavy
在接下来的两周里，你能做些什么来让自己当下感觉更好？你不需要去考虑长远。你不需要执着于经营自己或者把所有事都做完，我只希望你一次专注一件事，不要给自己太大压力，你一定能一步一个脚印地达成目标。我想今天我们的时间就到这里了。我知道这是一集很长的节目，所以非常感谢你能收听到这里。大家知道，我总是喜欢为那些坚持听到这里的忠实听众留下一点表情符号提示。所以今天，我希望你们留下一个你最喜欢的动物的表情符号。我不知道自己为什么要选这个。这似乎很有趣。这似乎很合适。考虑到这集节目如此沉重，这似乎也带有一点轻松的意味，
this episode was. So yes, drop your favorite animal as an emoji below. Remember, there are also resources listed in the description, ways to access help, further ways to educate yourself, whether you are someone with mass depression or someone helping a loved one. And I just want to send you a lot of love and healing. Like I know this is very difficult. Whatever is drawn you to this episode today and drawn you to listen this far, I'm sure it can sometimes feel quite heavy. So I'm with you in that pain. I'm with you in that struggle. I've been there and I can say that we do get better and life does feel amazing again. And if you unmask and if you let people in, it just gets so much lighter. So I really, I really want that for you. But until next time, my lovely,
所以是的，请在下方留下你最喜欢的动物的表情符号。记住，简介中也列出了各种资源，包括获取帮助的途径、进一步了解相关知识的方法，无论你是患有严重抑郁症的人，还是正在帮助挚爱的人。我只想向你们发送满满的爱与治愈。我知道这真的很不容易。无论是什么把你吸引到今天的节目中，又是什么吸引你听到了这里，我确信这有时会让人觉得相当沉重。所以我和你们一同承受这种痛苦。我和你们一同经历这种挣扎。我也曾经历过，我可以肯认的是，我们确实会好起来的，生活也一定会再次变得美好。如果你卸下伪装，如果你让别人走进你的世界，这一切就会变得轻松得多。所以我是真的很、真的很希望你能拥有这一切。但直到下一次，我可爱的、
lovely listeners. Make sure you are following me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Make sure you pre-order my book. It comes out in less than a month and I'd love to hear your thoughts on it when you finally get a copy. And until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness. fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
可爱的听众们。请确保在Instagram上关注我，账号是That Psychology Podcast。请务必预购我的书。它将在不到一个月后出版，当你终于拿到副本时，我很想听听你的想法。在下次见面之前，请照顾好自己。保持善良。对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代社会中关于心理韧性、体能训练以及培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟是同一个声名狼藉的爱情骗子时，她们决定自己动手解决问题。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的好闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客、
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it
或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。来自1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会带你回到过去，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着弄清楚我们是如何
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's, really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
你们正在收听的是由你最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，在IHard radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the hard way。
This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个IHart播客。保证真人创作。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。